good evening we feel very privileged to
be here particularly in this room full
of extraordinary pioneers we have the
privilege of honoring and unique fierce
voices in the arts so as a firm
mentioned by Cheryl I would like to
share a story about being the new kid
the new kid in town and for the first
time in my life I had the opportunity to
pick out something to wear for someone
for the first time I was nine years old
and that man would be Lynn Stoll master
it was my very first audition and yes as
one does I got to go to Bullock's
Wilshire in Westwood and pick out my own
outfit and since it was the late 70s I
really wanted to impress him so I got a
lime-green pantsuit um it had a matching
vest as well I just want you to fall to
know and I went in and the blessing
began I was introduced as a 9 year old
to a champion I was introduced to a man
who wasn't just looking to help me
understand if I should be an actor if I
had a skill at being an actor which was
really what I was looking for in this
audition experience but more so how he
could champion a girl that would grow
into a woman in finding her own voice
Lin patiently was with me and watched
and read with me in my audition and very
quickly supported me and in saying that
he believed this would be my path and
should be my path but more importantly
that I should do it on my own and he
presented that path for me he suggested
how to be fiercely independent from both
my parents who were beloved actors but
even more than that
that I deserved a childhood that I
deserve to grow and develop as a human
and know who I was in my own authentic
way in my own unique way as a girl and
so he proposed that I study for several
years first how to be my own person how
to find a casting director and an agent
and films and television to go audition
for without my parents knowing so that I
could find my way to my own craft my own
story Lin I can tell you that today I
know my own voice as not only an artist
for it as a woman because you set me on
the way to find a truthful place inside
myself beyond what it is to be an actor
and I am forever forever grateful for
you what an extraordinary gift you give
all of us in helping us find our way
you know when we honor Lin saw master
we're also honoring a group of people
that have been extremely kind of laid in
the background in our industry but we
have to remember that every movie that
was ever made was made with a casting
director and Lin stall master gave me
and my entire generation the opportunity
to dare to dream that we could make a
difference or matter and that was a he
saw some kind of light in her eyes or
something that he felt that he was going
to help us so what he did is he dared us
to go out on the edge he dared us to
take parts nobody other would know other
people would take and he gave us the
opportunity to have a chance to be in
good stuff I remember John Frankenheimer
told me while we were making black
Sunday if you got Lin's stall master to
cast your movie you have a goddamn good
chance of having a good movie so Lin
made you feel John Wayne okay so Lin you
know I've gone on too long but what I
really want to say when you get home
tonight sir you look in the mirror and
you realize that you'll install master
changed an industry